foreign
if you find it hard to get a good
night's sleep you're not alone a new
survey from Consumer Reports shows 9 to
10 Americans say they have struggled
with sleep in the last year and 29 say
they have taken prescription drugs
over-the-counter medicine or supplements
to improve their sleep that is me
Consumer Reports is out with new tips
and products that have recommendations
that may help you sleep a little bit
better cr's Tanya Christian joins us
right now good morning how you doing
good thanks for having me all right so
how did you go about compiling this list
of products yeah so first and foremost
we wanted to make sure that all the
products were going to help you sleep
right it doesn't make sense to spend
money on things that aren't actually
going to be beneficial so if we
recommended a product we want to make
sure that it was quiet like a humidifier
air purifier make sure it's quiet it
hasn't produced a lot of light these are
the things we you know put into
consideration we can file this list I
love Consumer Reports huge fan huge fan
you guys test everything yes if you're
feeling bad physically when you wake up
could be the mattress what's top rated
there it could so top rated for us is
the avocado green and we like it because
it's really helps a number of sleepers
back side stomach so whatever it is it's
kind of an all-around good mattress
that's good prices wait is that the
price that is the price I mean it's it's
not cheap but for a mattress they do run
a lot they do run a lot yeah for sure so
what about pillows because I woke up
with like a crick in my neck and I think
it was the pillow that I actually bought
and I think it's not serving anymore you
know the same thing with mattresses you
want to make sure that the pillow is
supporting your spine alignment that's
first and foremost so our Coop number
one rated pillow what's nice about it is
it's all around good support for any
kind of sleeper also it's adjustable so
it's you can take the some of the
filling out to kind of give you that
really customized feel all right so
um bedding is a big deal when it comes
to sleep we were just talking about it
during the commercial break and weighted
blankets they have all the buzz right
now oh yes I don't know I will sometimes
put the pillows actually on me as a kind
of weight really
what is it about weighted blankets yeah
so people like that gentle pressure
because it almost feels like you're
getting a warm hug and people like that
when they're sleeping so that's what it
is
great about weighted blankets they're
poor wives no snug at five minutes of
cuddling then I'm out that's it
we barely get that anymore I just I'll
just touch my wife
I'll be there but we're here together
good night
uh light in the room big issue right
thinking about other people getting up
at different times talking about eye
covers yes so you know a lot of people
like those room darkening Shades but
yeah and they're great but if you don't
want to spend that money you can get a
eye mask for twenty dollars on Amazon we
recommend the M Zoo it's great because
you're filtering out all those little
lights even if it's the TV indicator
light with the little red dot it's great
to filter out for a lot of people that
light sensitivity is a problem and
because of your circadian rhythm you
want to make sure that it's dark at
night so it signals when the light comes
out that it's time to wake up that
includes not looking at your phones at
night it does which is hard but yes so
talk to us about air quality some people
like to sleep with the window open but
you know when it's too cold outside that
might not be a good option yeah and most
people like it to be cool in their
bedroom and that's good because you
don't want to be disturbed by being hot
so we'd like to say in the 60s is a good
temperature yeah I've even gotten down
to 69 which is very cold for me but also
if you have a lot of allergens maybe you
have a pet consider an air purifier you
don't want to be sniffling throughout
the night or having those allergens dust
mites sometimes are on mattresses
anything that could prevent you from
going to sleep air purifiers can kind of
clean the air same thing with humidity
that goes into the air 30 to 50 percent
humidity is what you're looking for
you're having trouble with heat in your
room I got one low-tech fix I will
endorse right now okay just get that
left foot out
that'll cool you down so I've got a
little air just one foot out that's
going to regulate the temperature that
regulates everything I believe so okay
I'll get you those references yeah okay
thank you I appreciate that Tanya
Christian thank you so much for joining
us thank you we'll be right back we did
that